Johnny Depp's fourth day of evidence of
the high courts was yet another
Hollywood box-office event accused of
threatening his ex-wife with a knife mr.
Depp said an audio clip from July 2016
showed he was asking Amber Heard to cut
him why would I do that
don't please do not do that please do
not do that please don't
oh thank you no thank you
Amber Heard claims she was the victim of
domestic abuse at the hands of Johnny
Depp who's suing the Sun newspapers
publishers for libel over an article
describing him as a wife beater a photo
was shown in court of Miss herds bruised
face after Johnny Depp threw a phone at
her which he denies all after what's
become known as the defecation incident
mr. Depp described it as a fitting end
to their relationship after feces were
found in the couple's bed he believed
either left by Amber Heard or one of her
friends the only ones crass enough to do
it he said that incident came the
morning after Johnny Depp is accused of
throwing a magnum bottle of champagne at
Amber Heard grabbing her by the throat
and pushing her to the ground he denies
it but says it is possible that he left
a message saying happy expletive
birthday a text to misheard red I loved
you more than anything I did everything
that I could but you never loved me I
was merely convenient for you I hope our
divorce goes as quickly as possible I'll
miss the moments of beauty and truth
goodbye Johnny Depp denies all
allegations of domestic abuse today was
supposed to be his last day giving
evidence instead he'll be back next week
for another installment of what's become
a blockbuster courtroom battle Adele
Robinson Sky News at the High Court